This is what it is.
Good friend Bert is a
fucking raging alcoholic.
He drinks six doubles a night.
Yeah,
he's during a 12 drinks a night.
I'll tell you that in all honesty.
Once again,
so we said,
do you think you'd get
to where he said yes.
Okay,
so then someone said
sober and run a marathon.
I was like,
stop you guys.
He's going to die.
I have a problem with teetotaling
when I worked with him in Milwaukee,
Hawaii,
Miami.
So we said,
okay,
how about no drinking for the entire
month of October and you got to do 15 hot
yoga classes in a month.
Let's just,
let's just put the parameters down and
then just pretend you think I'm not lying
right now.
So everybody agreed to that and then a
couple of fucking days ago they started
saying,
we're going to be totally sober.
No weed,
no alcohol.
I go,
Whoa,
whoa.
Come on,
hold on.
Hold on.
One came once they sober,
we're talking,
we'd
when he's,
I can get into that place.
I can get into that.
No,
we'd place for him.
I don't know.
Do you want to be their eyes and they're
trying to shame me into Quinten pot.
Yeah.
You want to just put weed in the bucket
and we'll that we'll do we just in case.
Okay.
We should think about it.
We should definitely not do anything rash.
I like it.
I like pod.
I'm not willing to not do it for
an alcoholic friend and a welcher.
Yeah,
that was the goal.
Weight.
Get the tape measure.
Why?
What's the fucking tape measure?
Wow.
What a cheap piece of shit.
What ain't cheap teas.
15 days a yoga,
31 days sober.
All of October,
October.
Maybe I'll do it in November.
November this month.
They can suck my dick.
I'm going to get high every day.